[Music]
the US House of Representatives has
passed a resolution setting rules for
the Trump impeachment inquiry the first
formal vote on the issue in a divided
house the resolution is adopted without
objection the motion to reconsider is
laid upon the table members voted mostly
along party lines for weeks testimonies
have been conducted behind closed doors
these new measures will now make them
public witnesses have been questioned
about allegations the president
pressured Ukraine to investigate his
political rival Joe Biden well earlier
the House Speaker Nancy Pelosi said the
future of American democracy was at
stake this Constitution is the blueprint
for our republic and not a monarchy but
when we have a president who says
article 2 says I can do whatever I want
that is in defiance of the separation of
powers that's not what our Constitution
says so what does its take as our
democracy what are we fighting for
defending our democracy for the people
and here's what the top Republican
leader in the US House Kevin McCarthy
had to say today is more than the
fairness of an impeachment process it is
about the integrity of our electoral
process Democrats are trying to impeach
the president because they are scared
they cannot defeat him at the ballot box
in a moment we'll speak to our White
House correspondent Kimberly halket
first let's go to Heidi Joe Castro on
Capitol Hill in Washington DC so no
surprises here as expected the House of
Representatives the lower house of the
US Congress has approved this measure
right Heidi
that's right and it the approval was
largely along party lines which is what
had been expected of course you know
Democrats control the House of
Representatives but what was surprising
is that there were two Democratic
representatives who defected from their
caucus and voted with the unanimous
Republicans in not approving this
measure
obviously that fell short and finally
this measure was adopted what it does in
practice is it sanctions the
continuation of this impeachment inquiry
that has already impractical of weeks
but all of the witnesses that I come
through thus far have had closed-door
hearings with only scant information
leaking out now with this measure having
been passed the house will continue with
the inquiry in the eye of the public by
hosting public hearings Democrats have
faced accusations and criticism from
Republicans saying that these
proceedings have been to behind closed
doors that they're not transparent that
this is all part of a deep state
conspiracy against Donald Trump and now
having adopted this measure that will
open the proceedings to the public
Democrats are in essence deflating are
attempting to deflate that argument from
Republicans by bringing these
proceedings into the open and what we've
heard from witnesses thus far according
to their leaked opening statements has
been a pretty troubling narrative as
ascribed by Democrats of what Trump has
done using the power of his office in
their words to compel Ukraine to open
investigations into Trump's political
rivals at home and today on Capitol Hill
was yet another White House insider
speaking me for impeachment
investigators that was Tim Morrison who
is the Russia expert on the National
Security Council and named by previous
witnesses as a key figure in the inner
sinking of the White House at the time
of the security aid being
with help from Ukraine Morrison is
telling another Trump aide that he had
quote a sinking feeling when he learned
that Trump wanted the president of
Ukraine to go to a microphone and
announce these investigations into Joe
Biden so a lot of alarming testimony
Sammy that Democrats are hoping now will
be brought into the public eye by
sanctioning public hearings going
forward all right thanks so much Heidi
Joe Castro there our President Trump
tweeted his reaction immediately after
the vote saying simply the greatest
witch hunt in American history our White
House correspondent Kimberly halqa is
live for us in Washington DC and as that
tweet might indicate he's not entirely
happy at all with this entire process of
impeachment however my T takes some
comfort Kimberly and the fact that we
didn't have I think any Republicans
voting for a public impeachment process
I think the president is going to take
some comfort in that look in this White
House knew the vote was going to be a
foregone conclusion in terms of
Democrats will unanimously or
overwhelmingly vote for this to be a
formalized process they've made that
clear from the beginning so the White
House was prepared for it
they have sent out a statement the press
secretary calling this already we're
seeing how they're going to characterize
this that they see this is illegitimate
the president has done nothing wrong and
Democrats know that according to White
House press secretary Stephanie Grisham
you talked about how this was bipartisan
and it reminds me of the last time there
were impeachment proceedings in
Washington I was here for that back in
1998 it was a Democratic president in
the White House and when there was a
vote it was very notable there were 31
Democrats that voted with the
Republicans so we saw that there was
some bipartisan effort to prosecute
President Clinton we haven't seen that
so far but that was not the vote to
impeach Donald Trump that was the vote
to formalize things now we're going to
have these hearings coming out in the
open out of the shadows if you will
right now the US president has an
enormous base of support that seems to
be unaffected by the headlines so far
when these testimonies start to become
public we could see that change we could
then see some Republicans going with the
Democrats hard to predict how this is
going to fall out but for now you can
suffice to say the White House
well not surprised what happened from
the president's tweet they're the
greatest witch hunt in American history
clearly not happy about how things are
going so far all right thanks so much
Kimberly how cute man oh Michael Isikoff
is the chief investigative correspondent
at Yahoo News and co-author of Russian
roulette it joins us now live from
Washington DC good to have you with us
so will the vote today go towards
anywhere towards perhaps addressing some
of those Republican complaints that so
far the impeachment process has been
enough it has not been officially
adopted it has been too secretive well
now it has and this is a momentous day
that the house has now formally voted to
authorize this impeachment inquiry it
makes it all but inevitable that
President Trump will be impeached by the
full house there's a roadmap ahead for
the hearings going forward the public
hearings in which the Democrats will be
making their case to the public for why
they need to do this but I think there's
something significant legally
significant about what happened today
which is that it does strengthen the
Democrats hand in two very crucial court
hearings coming up as early as this
afternoon charles Kupperman
has gone to court after getting a
request to testify saying given that the
White House has invoked executive
privilege is he legally permitted to go
ahead and testify and one of the
arguments that's going to be argued in
court this afternoon separately there's
another court argument about
Don McGann who was the White House
Counsel during the Muller proceedings
who's also the Democrats want his
testimony as well having the house
formally vote gives the Democrats more
ammunition to argue that copper mints
testimony is needed in the impeachment
inquiry he was the deputy national
security adviser and if the judge in
that case judge Lyon who's hearing this
argument this afternoon approves that it
almost certainly would give a green
light to john bolton the national
security adviser to testify as well if
the democrats get Bolton's testimony
that could be political dynamite
it could be political dynamite this vote
does give the Democrats some more power
though in deciding or at least blocking
some of the White House's ability to
call witnesses right well under the
resolution if you read it carefully
chairman Schiff who will be conducting
the proceedings he's the chairman of the
House Intelligence Committee does have
the discretion to the Republicans can
request witnesses but Schiff has the
discretion to turn them down the
resolution says the Republicans have to
submit a written case for why they think
somebody's testimony is Michelle too
this impeachment inquiry so I yeah we'll
see how much latitude Schiff gives the
Republicans to call their own witnesses
I suspect the Democrats don't want this
to turn into a political circus in which
the Republicans try to call Joe Biden
for instance or hunter Biden to try to
make the proceedings about them rather
than the president's own conduct so you
know it's going to be very interesting
to see how the dynamic between the
Republican requests for witnesses and
how much latitude Schiff gives them
we're obviously still a bit away from a
final vote on impeachment but is there
anything to be read
to this vote in trying to predict how
the final vote might go well you know
the fact that it was almost entirely on
partisan lines is is noteworthy you had
two Democrats bolt who voted against no
Republicans not a single one voted for
this inquiry and if that stays the same
after the public hearings after the full
transcripts are released after all the
testimony is in if it remains a
Republican inquiry it's gonna make it
harder for Republican senators who are
ultimately going to be deciding the fate
of President Trump to vote to convict it
doesn't make it impossible because it's
all gonna rest on how strong that
evidence is how powerful their Democrats
make their public case but you know
clearly the Democrats and Speaker Pelosi
didn't want this to be a purely partisan
exercise right now it looks like largely
it is all right thanks so much for your
analysis on that